what we're going to do in this video is
think about how a person's environment
or experiences affects their political
perspective their political attitudes so
one way to think about it is how is your
socialization your political
socialization how does that drive your
political attitudes and I encourage you
pause this video think about your own
political leanings whether you lean to
the left or you lean to the right where
did that come from was it just you in a
vacuum thinking about things or were you
influenced by your family your friends
your school maybe the media maybe
something that you're part of maybe a
club or a church mosque synagogue or
temple and this is actually an area of
study for political scientists and as
you could imagine some of the things
that I just mentioned are significant
factors that people have studied in
terms of what develops people's
political attitudes if you come from a
family of staunch Democrat you're more
likely to be a Democrat or at least lean
to the left if the environment of your
school or what you were exposed to in
school leans one way or another you are
likely more likely to lean in that
direction if your friends go one
direction rather that could be a very
powerful influence obviously what you're
exposed to in the media and out of all
of these the one that's maybe the most
studied is the notion of family and to
appreciate this idea let's look at this
diagram right over here so I encourage
you to pause this video and see if you
can make sense of this before we do that
together all right it says percentage
intergenerational resemblance in
partisan orientation and this data is
from 1992 so it shows three different
scenarios one scenario where we are
looking at folks where both parents are
Democrats another scenario where we're
looking at folks were both parents are
Republicans and then another scenario
where there is no consistent
partisanship among parents so neither
they are split or maybe they are
independent and actually if we look at
this third scenario first you see that
it's a pretty symmetrical distribution
green shows of people whose parents show
no partisan preference 17% are pure in
depend
about 18% lean towards the Democrats 16%
lean to the Republican that's about the
same 14% are weak Democrats
14% of weak republicans 10% are strong
Democrats 10% are strong Republicans so
it's a pretty balanced distribution here
but then if you look at the scenario
where both parents are Democrats you see
that of those folks only what is this
this is 8 plus 6 is 14 plus 7 only 21%
are Republicans and if you go the other
way where both parents are Republicans
you have only 18 percent of those folks
become Democrats so this is just
interesting food for thought a lot of us
really like to believe including myself
that hey I've come to all of these
conclusions based on completely
impartial thoughts about how the world
should be but we are influenced by our
environment and especially from our
family and frankly even the folks who go
in a different direction than their
families that might have been because of
their family
maybe they decide that hey dad always
frustrated me one way or the other so
I'm gonna go the other way or item I'm
gonna rebel a little bit and I'm gonna
go the other way because I am a free
thinker but even in that situation you
are being influenced by your environment